début de conseil municipal mouvementé à
coignières il ya quelques jours le maire
jean-pierre sevestre a saisi le
procureur de la république pour des
irrégularités et des manquements
réglementaire très grave au sein de son
équipe depuis trois ans je suis attelé à
remettre je dirais d'aplomb un petit peu
juridiquement et réglementairement la
maison car nous avions effectivement une
gestion auparavant qu'ils négligeaient
parfois la réglementation en ligne de
mire le précédent maire de la ville
henri pailleux et l'instituteur et
adjoint en charge de la culture ali
bousselham une délégation qui vient de
lui être retiré par arrêté jean-pierre
sevestre lui reprochent notamment
d'occuper un logement de 140 mètres
carrés sans payer de loyer depuis six
ans une situation que l'adjoint se
refuserait à régulariser j'estime que
c'est injuste de me déshonorer pour
quelque chose qui n'est pas injuste qui
n'est pas en tout cas qui n'est pas lui
qui n'est pas légal quoi on nomme
d'honneur je proposerai à ce que
monsieur se baissent de retirer cela si
le retire
écoutez je me ravise régénérait pas
ester en justice parce que voilà c'est
ça qui est gênant pour des raisons de
sécurité l'assemblée vote le report du
conseil et une date ultérieure dans un
lieu plus grand